colin kaepernick
six years now is it since he made a big
spectacle of himself and said that
america's evil and disrespected the flag
and was booted from the nfl
and then made a lot more money
selling hatred of america through
sneakers than he ever would have made in
the nfl
colin kaepernick is back
begging begging to be let back into the
nfl
are you willing to be do what carmelo
anthony did if an opportunity presented
itself today and they said we want to
bring you in as the backup would you
take that yeah you'll take that
if the opportunity i know i have to find
my way back in okay so
yeah if i have to come in as a backup
that's fine
but that's not where i'm that's not
where i'm staying and when i prove
that i'm a starter
i want to be able to step on the field
as such
i just need that opportunity to walk
through the door
he just wants that opportunity and he's
willing to even go through some hardship
for that he knows look he knows it's
really valuable for a person to be able
to play in the nfl and he knows he's
been out of it for a little while and so
he's gonna he'll he'll work as he'll do
a little bit of grunt work he'll be the
backup quarterback and then he's gonna
work his way up because he needs to get
back he just wants so deeply his desire
his will is to get back into the nfl
this from colin kaepernick the same man
who what a year or two ago said that
playing for the nfl is like working as a
slave on a plantation in the antebellum
south
what they don't want you to understand
is what's being established
is a power dynamic
before they put you on the field
teams poke
pride and examine you
searching for any defect that might
affect your performance no boundary
respected
no dignity left intact
come on boys
look at that shape there look at this
mr fiber i got your bid 30.
[Music]
look at this here
come on who wants this
700. there we go now
i'm telling you what i want
so
here we go there are the shackles
colin you're free
you're free colin you were previously
enslaved by the nfl
you had that awful slavery of being
really rich and famous and getting to do
the thing that you trained your whole
life to do
and now you're free from that
you're free and you get to be a clown
you're afraid to you're liberated into
clowndom you're the guy he looks like a
clown he talks like a clown
he is a clown
that's what he does now please no let me
go back into slavery oh you don't really
think it's slavery you just you're very
confused he's a very confused man
and actually
though he is not aware of this this does
speak to our misunderstanding of
liberation
the way we understand liberation today
is that you don't have any obligations
you are not bound by any limits
whatsoever be they political
cultural or even natural so you're not
even bound by the limits of your own sex
you get to just do whatever you want
whenever you want to do it colin
kaepernick wants to go out there and
make a big clown of himself and
disrespect america and the flag and the
fans and he wants to and
there's not going to be any consequences
for that right
no
because by the way sporting events have
always had a connection to patriotism
going back to ancient greece
so no now the consequence is he's out
but no i'm i don't i no no please can i
have the slavery again no you don't i'm
sorry colin there's actually
you will find far more freedom
in
limits
the heroin addict breaks all of the
chains breaks all of the limits he can
do whatever he wants whenever he wants
to do it except he can't and he's just a
slave to sin
then he's just a slave
to vice
right now go to epicwill.com
use promo code knowles i frankly i just
went back and redid my will
myself
epic will they got me thinking
i got a little baby i got to do the
responsible thing it's very important
that someday we're all going to go when
i go
that
the assets that i have are
spent in the way that i want them to be
in a way that i think is good that my
loved ones are going to be taken care of
okay if you do not have a will in place
you have no say in the future of your
children let that sink in
your kids your most precious asset if
you have not made a will yet you're not
alone but we're going to make it super
easy for you go to epicwill.com
when you use promo code knowles you will
get a wonderful incredible package
starting at just 119
when you use promo code noles you will
save 10
it's super duper easy so right now go to
epicwill.com
[Music]
this is the most important five minutes
that you are going to spend all day
glad you liked that clip now please
ring the bell subscribe get all the
notifications check out i got this great
new video where we were at washburn
university and i actually ended up
sitting down with the gal who organized
a protest against me really really
surprising exchange go check it out
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you